eva longoria debuts her adorable baby  bump the 42 year old actress was spotted  out for the first time since announcing  she's expecting her first child with  husband Jose boost on next year eva  dressed in casual attire rocking forest  green overalls and a white t-shirt with  her belly on full display while shopping  with friends in Miami Florida a rep for  Eva confirmed to ET she and Jose are  expecting a baby boy back in April Eva  shot down pregnancy rumors on snapchat  after photos surfaced online of the  actress in a bikini I saw some pictures  of myself really fat on a boat to tell  you all I did was eat cheese I love when  you went on snapchat and told people it  was just cheese y'all I'm not buying  them er down we need to keep an eye on  our snapchat when you do have something  to announce this is B stands for 'the  child Longoria's first the two tied the  knot in Acapulco Mexico in May 2016  [Music]  you